[Aplausos]
[Música]
francia es el país en el que nació la
extrema derecha tal y como la conocemos
hoy en día tal cual como lo es antes de
que estallara la crisis financiera
internacional mucho antes de que donald
trump ganara las elecciones en eeuu
antes incluso del presi y de esa oleada
de nacionalismo que azota europa mucho
antes de todo eso
francia ya contaba con su propio partido
de extrema derecha el frente nacional
con posibilidades reales de ganar las
elecciones
[Música]
es más fue en el año 2002 cuando el
resto de partidos tanto de centroderecha
como de centroizquierda tuvieron que
unir sus fuerzas para evitar que
jean-marie le pen ganara las elecciones
a la presidencia francesa y justo este
mes abril de 2017 los franceses van a
volver a las urnas y no son pocos los
que piensan que esta va a ser la ocasión
definitiva el momento en el que la
extrema derecha con marín le pen a la
cabeza conseguirá hacerse con la
presidencia francesa de una vez por
todas si esto fuera así la propia marine
lepén ya ha prometido que hará todo
cuanto esté en su mano para sacar a
francia de la unión europea pero no sólo
eso un triunfo de la extrema derecha en
francia supondría toda una victoria
moral para el resto de partidos
xenófobos en todo el mundo
pero esperad un momento porque la
pregunta que cabe hacerse es realmente
tiene posibilidades reales de ganar la
presidencia marín le pen quien puede
pararla en su carrera hacia el elíseo
hoy vamos a responder a todas esas
preguntas y vamos a contaros la historia
de la extrema derecha francesa
una historia que incluye choques de egos
batallas familiares y hasta conejitas de
playboy
vamos con ello
el clan de 'los lepe en la extrema
derecha francesa tiene dos abuelos
ideológicos hitler y la oas tal cual
como lo oís como sabéis durante la
segunda guerra mundial los alemanes
invadieron el norte de francia
el sur de francia esa llamada zona libre
también estaba ocupada por un gobierno
cuya capital era la ciudad francesa de
vichy y que tenía unas ideas
completamente afines al partido
nacionalsocialista alemán cuando termina
la guerra
el nuevo presidente galo el general
charles de gaulle ejecuta a los
principales cabecillas de este gobierno
colaboracionista pero espera de un
momento porque eso no significa que
terminara con todos los sectores que
apoyaban a los nacionalsocialistas
es decir que todavía quedaba muchísima
gente que aunque no tuviera poder
político todavía apoyaba esta ideología
y ojo porque muchos de ellos estaban en
el ejército
años más tarde concretamente en el año
1961 francia permite que su colonia más
preciada argelia celebre un referéndum
de autodeterminación
[Aplausos]
y como os podéis imaginar esto no sentó
nada bien a todos esos sectores de
extrema derecha que estaban en el
ejército francés y así es como nace la
oas una organización terrorista cuyo
principal objetivo es acabar con los
independentistas argelinos no somos
terroristas somos patriotas estamos en
deuda con los soldados que murieron
luchando en argelia y con los 3 millones
de ciudadanos franceses que viven allí
en 1962
argelia se constituye como un estado
independiente y los miembros de la oas
intentan acabar con el propio presidente
charles de gaulle porque lo consideran
un traidor a la patria
por suerte en 1965 la policía francesa
desmanteló los últimos comandos de esta
organización pero esperad un momento
porque aquí no termina la historia al
igual que ocurrió tras la segunda guerra
mundial acabar con los principales
cabecillas no significa que no quedará
gente que apoyará las mismas ideas
francia ese país famoso por la libertad
la igualdad y la fraternidad es también
el hogar de muchísimos sectores sociales
que obvian a los argelinos e incluso
añoran el tercer reich y esos son los
mimbres que diez años más tarde
utilizaría jean marie le pen para fundar
el frente nacional
la prensa en la que habla todo el día de
la guerra la persecución de los judíos y
los excesos de la ocupación
los comienzos no fueron cosa fácil
durante los años 70
el frente nacional no subía del 5 por
ciento de los votos incluso el propio
jean marie le pen sufrió un atentado en
su propia casa y esperado un momento
porque aquí llega la parte divertida de
la historia en 1977 la familia lepén
hereda por parte de un empresario
francés afín al frente nacional nada
menos que uno
[Música]
el palacio de monte tout este palacio se
convertirá enseguida en la sede no
oficial del frente nacional o lo que es
lo mismo de la familia lepén porque mis
queridos amigos de visual político en
este partido político todo queda en
familia desde esta mansión monté tu jean
marie le pen organizaba esas campañas
políticas que en los años 80 le llevaron
a convertirse nada menos que en la
tercera fuerza política mientras tanto
su hija marie le pen le seguía en sus
quehaceres diarios y aprendía todos los
secretos del arte de la política
profesional para convertirse en la
lideresa que es ahora más tarde también
se le uniría su nieta
marion marichal de penn que ahora mismo
también es diputada del frente nacional
pero esperad un momento porque aunque
este partido se presente como el campeón
de los valores familiares
lo cierto es que la familia le pen está
menos unida de lo que parece y sí ya sé
que en visual polític no nos gusta
hablar de cotilleos ni de la vida
privada de nadie pero es que en este
caso es estrictamente necesario para
entender la vida y la historia política
del frente nacional que como os decía en
los años 80 jean marie le pen que a
partir de ahora le vamos a empezar a
llamar lepén padre para diferenciarle de
los demás
estaba on fire cada elección sacaba más
votos que la anterior y en ese momento
es cuando decide contratar a un
periodista para que le escriba su
biografía y por supuesto le ofrece
acomodo en su mansión en este palacio
monte tube
y que creéis que hizo este escritor pues
nada menos que seducir a la mujer del
epen padre al cual como lo oís no sólo
eso
estos dos amantes huyeron de la mansión
abandonaron a jean marie le pen y meses
más tarde su mujer aparecía en la
portada de la revista playboy así es
como el mundo entero descubrió el lado
más sensual de la extrema derecha como
os podéis imaginar todo esto supuso un
auténtico cisma en el clan lepén así que
no importaba que el padre subiera en
votos
su hija cada vez estaba más distante
pero el auténtico punto de inflexión de
este clan lepén llegó en el año 2002
en ese año francia celebró unas
elecciones presidenciales
[Aplausos]
y por primera vez en la historia lepén
pasó a la segunda vuelta como ya sabéis
el sistema electoral francés tiene dos
vueltas es decir que cuando van a elegir
presidente primero hacen unas elecciones
a las que se presentan todos los
candidatos al elíseo 345 los que sean
[Aplausos]
después de esta votación hacen una
segunda en la que solo se presentan los
dos candidatos que más votos sacaron en
la primera pues bien en este año 2002
los dos candidatos que consiguieron
pasar a la segunda vuelta fueron jacques
chirac del partido de centroderecha y
jean-marie le pen de la extrema derecha
y os preguntaréis cómo es posible que
los dos candidatos fueras de derechas
acaso no hay partidos socialdemócratas
en francia
[Música]
y es que durante todos estos años los
lepén aprendieron una lección política
muy importante los votos cautivos no
existen así que aunque el frente
nacional sea un partido de extrema
derecha su programa electoral incluye
muchísimas propuestas muy atractivos
para todos aquellos que viven en las
zonas obreras y en las zonas
industriales no olvidéis que el epen
defiende el proteccionismo no sólo para
las empresas francesas sino también para
los trabajadores os suena eso de los
americanos primero pues no es un invento
de donald trump ya lo decía jean marie
le pen en los años 90 pero con los
franceses así que en este año 2002
ciudades industriales como marsella que
tradicionalmente habían votado a
partidos de centroizquierda se volcaron
con el frente nacional
[Música]
y por eso en esta segunda vuelta los
votantes del partido socialista francés
tuvieron que tragarse su orgullo y votar
al candidato de centroderecha como os
podéis imaginar cualquier cosa era buena
con tal de evitar que un político
filonazi y xenófobo como jean marie le
pen se hiciera con la presidencia
[Música]
y así es como el clan de penn aprendió
una segunda lección en política no sólo
vale con cautivar a tus votantes sino
que tampoco puedes asustar demasiado a
los de los otros partidos de lo
contrario pueden formar un frente común
contra ti y evitar que llegues a
gobernar y por eso ocurrió lo que vamos
a ver ahora
marín versus jean marie versus marion la
navidad dejó de ser dulce monte tout a
partir de 2002 en ese momento es cuando
marín the pain comenzó su campaña
interna en contra de su propio padre no
olvidéis que jean-marie le pen es un
político que se presenta a las
elecciones con perlas como estas
[Música]
tiene que haber una autoridad y pensamos
que en una casa el más cualificado para
ejercer esa autoridad es el hombre
marie le pen sin embargo es una mujer
dispuesta a utilizar toda su autoridad
política para limpiar la imagen de un
partido que haría que hasta windows 95
parezca algo moderno a diferencia de su
padre
marín le pen está en contra de la pena
de muerte y a favor de la unión de
parejas homosexuales todo esto son cosas
que hasta los votantes del frente
nacional son capaces de apreciar y por
eso en el año 2011 le pen hija sucede a
su padre como presidenta del partido
pero esperad un momento porque las cosas
nunca fueron fáciles
me pregunto qué le motiva a marín y a
sus diputados para haber lanzado esta
campaña contra mí lo cierto es que
cuando ha sido el presidente y fundador
de la extrema derecha francesa durante
la friolera de 39 años es muy difícil
hacer
que tu hija te dé órdenes así que a día
de hoy jean marie le pen es el
presidente honorario del frente nacional
pero en el parlamento europeo vota por
su cuenta jefe hice campaña por
jean-marie le pen no por marine lepén y
gane por el 33% ya que no adivina quién
es su principal apoyo dentro del partido
efectivamente marion lepén nieta de jean
marie le pen quien a su vez está
empezando su propia guerra interna
contra su tía marina
él es un provocador un anti conformista
y eso no es siempre bonito de escuchar
mientras tanto la moderación de marín
depende en combinación con la salida de
la crisis económica en francia está
funcionando mucho mejor que las
estrategias y la retórica electoral de
su padre
conozco a áfrica y consideró que europa
ha cometido un error en el pasado
debería haber establecido relaciones de
cooperación de desarrollo económico con
áfrica porque creo que es una de las
maneras de fijar a las poblaciones en su
país de origen exacto de hecho los
últimos sondeos para estas elecciones de
2017 le dan cerca de un 25 por ciento de
intención de voto lo que la coloca entre
la primera y la segunda candidata mejor
valorada en unos comicios donde hay
cinco candidatos con posibilidades de
gobernar un 25 por ciento de intención
de voto es todo un triunfo
es casi seguro que marín de penn pasará
a la segunda vuelta
pero esperad un momento porque el hecho
de que sea menos radical que su padre no
significa ni muchísimo menos que marine
lepén sea una política moderada en esos
ya famosos 144 puntos de los que se
compone su programa electoral lepén
defiende el cierre de fronteras la
deportación masiva de inmigrantes la
salida del euro y por supuesto la vuelta
al franco francés en todo caso comparto
con vladimir putin parte de su visión
económica es cierto y no es algo que
venga de ayer pero esperad un momento
porque ahora os estaréis preguntando
realmente puede lepe en convertirse en
la nueva presidenta francesa ahora mismo
lo vamos a ver
bien puede frenar al epen durante años
el centroderecha francés veía como el
frente nacional podía comerse a buena
parte de su electorado bien es cierto
que el epen había absorbido muchos votos
de los caladeros tradicionales del
centroizquierda pero también es cierto
que en época de crisis los mensajes de
valores familiares y cierre de fronteras
pueden ser muy atractivos entre los
votantes conservadores así que en 2016
el gran partido del centroderecha
francés los republicanos eligen como
candidato a un hombre que incorpora
todas esas propuestas que habían hecho
famosos a los lepén
ese hombre es françois fillón
y ahora os preguntaréis está funcionando
esta estrategia de los republicanos para
frenar al frente nacional pues lo cierto
es que parece que no los republicanos
desde que filón es el candidato no han
dejado de caer en las encuestas y ahora
mismo se pelean con el candidato de
extrema izquierda
jean-luc mélenchon por el tercer puesto
los escándalos sexuales y de corrupción
y el hecho de que los votantes prefieren
siempre el original a la copia han
sumido al centroderecha en el olvido
[Música]
pero esperad un momento porque la
batalla no ha terminado todavía queda un
hombre dispuesto a frenar el huracán le
pen su nombre es emmanuel macrón
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y viene de ser el ministro de economía
del gobierno socialdemócrata de manuel
valls y os preguntaréis es emmanuel
macrón un socialdemócrata pues no
emanuel macrón se presenta a estas
elecciones como un candidato
independiente e incluso el propio manuel
valls que fue quien le eligió como
ministro no le ha dado su apoyo
públicamente hasta finales de marzo y no
olvidéis que las elecciones son en abril
y que defiende emanuel macrón pues
básicamente lo contrario que le pedí
macrón quiere acabar con todos los
privilegios de los que gozan las
empresas subvencionadas por el estado y
eliminar las barreras en el mercado
laboral que impiden que los jóvenes
puedan encontrar un trabajo por supuesto
está en contra de discriminar a nadie
por razones de raza o religión en
materia económica ha presentado un
programa de responsabilidad fiscal para
reducir el déficit público y por si todo
esto fuera poco una de sus propuestas
consiste en prohibir a los altos cargos
que enchufen a sus familiares en puestos
del gobierno vamos que es la antítesis
absoluta del clan lepén pero no os
preocupéis porque trataremos más a fondo
este tema en otro vídeo lo importante
ahora es que manuel macrón está
superando ya el 25 por ciento de
intención de voto de hecho las últimas
encuestas ya le ponen por encima del
frente nacional
[Música]
que pese a ser un candidato
independiente es el hombre con más
posibilidades de enfrentarse a marine
lepén en la segunda vuelta pero esperad
un momento porque todavía hay un factor
decisivo en estas elecciones la
abstención
[Música]
por ejemplo si en una segunda vuelta
marine lepén consiguiera mantener el 90%
de sus apoyos y macrón solo se quedara
en un 40 un 50% lo tendría muy difícil
para hacerse con la presidencia francesa
y si algo caracteriza a estos partidos
nacionalistas son sus aversiones
incondicionales
[Aplausos]
y queréis ver el vídeo en el que hacemos
una radiografía de los partidos
xenófobos europeos podéis hacer clic en
este enlace
y ahora la pregunta es creéis que manuel
macro no puede hacer frente a marine
lepén o tal vez en algún momento de
estas elecciones algunos de los otros
candidatos conseguir a repuntar en las
encuestas
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y no olvidéis que sacamos
vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así que
suscribiros al canal para no perderos
ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones si
os ha gustado este vídeo dadle a like y
nos vemos en el próximo un abrazo y
hasta pronto